now we know you're a pretty good liar
but what
you're caught by the enemy and faced
with a lie detector test
okay if you are being polygraphed
it's already too late hi i'm michelle
rigby assad a former intelligence
officer with the cia
i spent the majority of my career in the
middle east doing counter-terrorism and
counterintelligence work
and today we're going to review
television and movie clips to see
are they real or not
do you see anything all right get closer
i can't tell if he's got the card on him
anything yeah the key card's in his
breast pocket
the idea of having an earpiece where you
have
immediate support and targeting
assistance as you're carrying out your
your operation no that does not happen
i've never used multiple wigs during an
operation
or different sets of clothes i have
changed my appearance
i have put my hair up into a ponytail or
put
a hat on or changed a shirt or taken a
shirt off
it's very rare in your career to require
a big change of appearance um like you
would see
here in this clip hold
that for 30 seconds the duplicate key
card's printing
the the high-tech nature of that piece
being able to
read the key card and be able to then
create a new one based off of that
i've never heard of that before
wonderful yes yes well of course
getting funding is very difficult
particularly in the days
it's the oddest thing you could be on
the edge of the earth in a place that's
not very well known and
you could actually recognize a cia
classmate or colleague but what you do
not cross
paths you do not acknowledge each other
because you could both be in the middle
of an operation now we
try really hard to deconflict operations
so you don't want to greet them with the
wrong name so you just kind of like
wink at each other and keep walking so i
would rate this clip
as a one not realistic at all
i know how much jim in particular meant
to you ethan
yeah it isn't unusual to have an
operational
meeting in a restaurant they are seated
right next to
the glass front of the building you
would never sit there
because presumably anybody walking by on
the street has a clear view of this
operational meeting taking place with
high-end restaurants you're going to get
waiters and wait staff they're
incredibly
attentive to your needs as a diner and
you don't want that
you want to scope out the restaurant and
get a seat
towards maybe the back or the side of a
restaurant
you don't want it too noisy you don't
want it too quiet
and you also want to know where the back
entrance is
so you want to be able to come and go
from separate entrances and exits
after a meeting with a clandestine store
so this whole scenario would have never
actually taken a place in real life why
was there another team
what of imf agents at the embassy
tonight
absolutely not that would never ever
happen and the reason is
you have to have a full understanding of
everyone involved in the operation
everything you've done is fully planned
out and deconflicted with people in the
area so if you were to notice the other
team
you would have called out out the
operation from the beginning
i can understand you're very upset
kitridge you've never seen me
very upset that part is accurate the
sense of no matter what happens you have
to keep your
head on straight you have to focus and
think okay
what next
[Music]
they certainly make intel officers look
incredibly cool
and who doesn't want explosive gum love
that
i would give it a 2 out of 10
for realism which doesn't mean i don't
absolutely love this movie
i do but not realistic at all
i was given specific instructions by
elaine to tailor these gadgets to you
nothing on that table we wouldn't be
using anything of that nature
the things that we are assigned when we
go to war zone or things like
your glock or your helmet or your kevlar
vest
when you are having an operation that
requires a piece of technology then you
will go through a very
long process of figuring out what the
best tech is for that scenario
it's not issued to you until you request
it
until you require that this anti-fungal
spray can freeze and disable
any security system what i love about
the silly items that he gives her
are things she can stash in her purse
and her suitcase
and no one's ever really going to think
twice about the idea
is to not stand out
she's successful in this movie because
she's the unexpected spy
you don't want people to take note of
you we talk about
lulling people to sleep back stopping
like you're creating a persona
and the person is that you're just a
normal everyday person and you even
need things like this i give it a three
um but of course for for fun
i give it a 10.
i can tell you the license plate numbers
of all six cars outside
i can tell you that our waitress is
left-handed and the guy sitting up at
the counter weighs 215 pounds and knows
how to handle himself
now his powers of recall are quite
incredible
and unrealistic essentially you're
trained to remember
people's profiles when they stand out
when they do something that's unusual or
different
you're conducting a surveillance
detection route so you're making sure
nobody's going to follow you
to your clandestine meeting you want to
make sure that you don't see the same
cars
twice and so one technique that they
teach us
is to speak out loud a description of
the various vehicles that you're seeing
so it's called commentary driving
[Music]
this whole scenario would have never
actually taken a place in real life
we learn how to use our car as a weapon
in case we're ambushed you learn how to
drive a car
really drive it to its limits how to
avoid impacting casuals in the field i
mean
it is it's the best it's like the
coolest part of our training but you
hope you will never
use any of it and so i was driving in my
car alone
and i was in the process of possibly
getting
carjacked i had to use my vehicle
um to hit someone a couple of times to
get them to move so i could drive
out of harm's way and um
i didn't think too much what i was doing
about what as i was in this
in the middle of this scenario but my
training kicked in thank god
and i was able to get away and
thankfully i also didn't
hurt that person i would give it
a 2 out of 10 for realism
[Music]
the idea that we we shoot people or we
have
black belts and martial arts and we take
people down
with a kick the psychology of espionage
is
very on the down low and not kind of in
your face
action-packed sequences we did get some
physical training and most of it was you
know what you do
if things go really bad we get qualified
on a glock
and we feel quite comfortable with the
glock after that training
so i would rate this clip as a one
the game we were in paris we uncovered
correspondence between suleiman
and his brother ali so the way this
scene is set up
with a room full of intelligence
officers from very very senior level
all the way down to junior type officers
is quite unusual it might remind you of
something you have seen in the press and
that
is president obama sitting with his
closest
security and intelligence advisors as
the operation
against usama bin laden unraveled they
were right there along the way they
heard the communications and you see
them sitting in the room together
so most of the time that doesn't happen
that would have to be an incredibly
high level type operation but you would
always have people in the room who are
subject matter experts
you could speak up as a junior officer
because you may be the only one in the
room who actually
has the substance or the knowledge about
your target
they were using a video game systems
online messaging app
to communicate so terrorists and other
criminals
have actually used the chat function in
games
to communicate with each other they have
used it as a form of
covert communications we have the
calculation of
risk versus gain so would we try to
insert ourselves
in a relationship between two really
close brothers
you would walk into that probably
understanding that you would not be able
to
have the proper verbal paroles to make
the connection
he's got this let's go guys get on it
get on it
most of our operations are not as
quickly unfolding or as rapid as this
one
the cia is very much a bureaucracy like
every us government agency
and it takes us a long time to plan
implement execute operations there are
very
very few instances in your career where
something
like that would happen where you're kind
of jumping through hoops and
looking up information quickly i mean we
do do that
but it's not it's not as prevalent as
this clip would make you think
he's still online jack
i love the authenticity of showing how
terrorists operate especially using the
gaming chat
um although you know hollywood amps it
up a bit
but because of all that i give it about
a seven
this clip makes me sweat
because it is so realistic in terms of
what we deal with when we're
crossing borders or getting ready to
board a flight or enter or exit a
country it can be
incredibly dicey and like i feel all
sweaty and my heart is racing even
thinking about it right now
you have to be so confident
in keeping your cover and maintaining
your legend
even if your insides are feel like
they're literally exploding
you cannot show that on your face you
have to remember who you are what your
name is what you're doing
what your purpose was in the country
when you entered when you exited
in terms of your cover story you want to
keep it as close to the truth as
possible because you have to memorize it
and you have to recall it easily
and you have to recall it under stress
this movie is based on a real-life
situation
which is right after the 1979 iranian
revolution
some americans were able to escape the
embassy and with the help of the
canadian government
come up with this operation to get them
out so
not only is it realistic but it really
did happen they did
actually have university students
putting
those photos together to try to figure
out the identities of all of the
us embassy staff what was the purpose of
your visit
we are looking for locations for a film
airport authorities don't even have to
have a good reason to detain you
or to stop you from boarding a flight if
they don't like the way you look
or they don't trust you or you say
something wrong
that could change the course of your
entire life technology has changed a
great deal
since 1979 when this happened and it's
making it
more difficult for intelligence officers
and others to cross borders covertly
because now
we've got all kinds of thumb prints and
eye scanners and all kinds of equipment
that's used to
establish your identity this one i give
a nine
because it's so close to accurate
i really don't want to do this anymore
and i mean it carrie i feel like i can't
even breathe now all you have to do now
is keep your eyes and ears open for the
remainder of your contract with the
prince
so i love this clip because it really
shows the bread and butter
of what it is to be an intelligence
officer the way that she handles her
source is
not ideal she basically said you have to
do this
oh my goodness you would never say that
to a real source
they are there because they want to be
there they are there because they
understand the risk and they're willing
to take the risk
now what you have to do is if they're
nervous
if they're concerned about moving
forward or they feel like their life is
in danger
you have to talk them through that you
have to
train them and so the idea of
telling her like you have to do this is
the worst
way to treat a source every time you
have a source needing
if there's a lot on the line with the
source it's almost like you have to
re-recruit them
every time you are the only agency asset
to have had eyes on his ear in seven
years
asset we do in fact call our sources
assets but we would never do that to
their face
because it's a very inhuman way to refer
to them and they
are human beings i am just some girl
from sandusky ohio
you talked into helping out our country
and i won't let anything happen to you
we are not god that we can protect our
sources
there are certain things in certain
situations that we can do
to help our sources out but the end of
the day
they're the ones on the front lines
they're the ones in difficult situations
and they're the ones who have to make a
decision so you have to
help them think through scenarios um
ways to ensure that they keep themselves
safe and don't
take any unnecessary risks your sources
may not intuitively know
what's too risky what they can get away
with and if at the end of the day they
don't feel comfortable
they can walk away at any time but the
part of this that
is inaccurate to me is the fact that a
a western woman who is the girlfriend of
a shake
would be anywhere remotely close to a
wanted terrorist that would not happen
she is unvetted untested fundamentally
she's a western woman
so that whole scenario is exactly
i would give this clip an eight only
because
it is the closest thing to a real life
covert meeting with the source that i
have ever seen in the movies or on
television
now we know you're a pretty good liar
but what you're caught by the enemy and
faced with a lie detector test okay if
you are being polygraphed it's already
too late
if you are arrested or detained by
foreign government
and you're being polygraphed done you're
finished
you don't even want to get to that point
the key is to focus on your breathing
the slightest increase in your blood
pressure is an indicator that you're not
telling the truth
so no we are not trained how to defeat
the polygraph
because you know once that happens
you're already probably imprisoned so
that's that's not
accurate at all the agency uses the
polygraph as part of your security and
background investigation
so basically if you train someone to
defeat it you're training your employees
to defeat one of the methods you use to
keep them
honest so they would never want to do
something like that
i could probably make arrangements for
you to end your tour of duty in san
diego
in which case i'll presume you'll forget
we ever had this conversation
getting personally recruited in that
manner
so while i know a couple of people that
that happened to
the vast majority of us actually apply
to the cia
online or through through someone that
we know next day we started this
tradecraft
wow no it could take an entire year for
the cia
to vet you and you have to go through
so many processes of polygraphs
and very long interviews and psych exams
and so you have to go through a battery
of tests before you get to the part
where you're actually going through
training now in terms of your tradecraft
training
that takes about a year and it's very
very intense and it's not one-on-one
like you see here you have classroom
time and then you have role playing in
the field
and you do go out in public and you
practice your skills
so that part is accurate i always carry
cigarettes in the lighter too it's a
great icebreaker now the whole
cigarette's in a lighter
they can be very useful especially in
parts of the world where smoking is a
big thing
so i spent a lot of time in the middle
east and a lot of people smoked they
were quite useful for was when you were
serving in really dangerous places where
there are a lot of
military or criminal checkpoints a pack
of cigarettes or a box of cigarettes
could potentially save your life
it's very valuable in certain parts of
the world so you would keep that in your
glove compartment box suit
in the kitchen thread
wait how did you see that
every time we can use a mirror
or a glass door or a glass window to see
your reflection
oh that's the best intelligence officers
love reflections
solicit information from someone
gladly elicitation is one of the most
important skills that you have as an
intelligence officer so you need to be
able to talk people into doing things
for you
you need to have the emotional
intelligence that allows you to make a
connection
to ultimately recreate recruit and
handle sources
or just to kind of get through your day
maintain your cover
and your you know intel your lifestyle
abroad whatever that is
but those are really critical skills i
read this is seven
it's there's some inauthentic pieces but
i like it as a whole
mr al masri mr omar sadiki
so what i find inauthentic about the
scene
is that you have your target and then
an operator almost crossing paths that
would never happen in real life
so of course what's happening here is
the target is being set up to be
photographed with another individual
you would have coordinated in an
operation like this way ahead of time
and not
in the actual office where it's going to
occur this is what you call the
operational bubble
and you have to get outside that
operational bubble to do something like
photograph these two and you saw this
huge lens
that he's using that's gonna grab a lot
of attention
so it's highly likely someone would have
seen him in the car with this ginormous
lens
if there'd been another car on the other
side of him possibly
but he wouldn't even need a lens that
big because he's really not that far
away
we would have definitely created a
scenario where you get your target into
a specific location
but you want to protect your technical
asset who's taking the photograph so you
want them to be
outside the operational bubble so that's
the part that's
that's not authentic here i probably
give it around a six
so slightly authentic but there are a
lot of problems
here as we've pointed out so who doesn't
love melissa mccarthy and spy
i laugh out loud in this movie she's so
brilliant